a hundred billion company this is a
pretty exciting time for
entrepreneurship you're at that point in
your stage like this gets important the
cost of failure of starting a business
today is by far the lowest it's ever
been business advice to Harley 10 years
ago you got one thing you can tell
him welcome everybody to the game I got
a special episode for you guys today as
you know I do not have many guests on my
podcast I don't like sharing the
spotlight um so if somebody's gonna be
on they've got to be really really
special
and have true expertise uh to give and I
think uh the person I have with me today
or that will be joining us today
definitely meets that in Spades and so
Harley is uh a god amongst men a legend
in in the making and uh runs a a small
company you may not have heard of it uh
Shopify uh which right now is a publicly
traded company it's worth right now I
think it was 80 billion uh if I'm not
mistaken hardly correct me there closer
to is closer to 100 billion but yeah
that was 20 billion off you you just
round it down by2 billion which for
someone like me like you know this is
like I don't come from this world this
is you know I'm I'm a tourist here uh
that's a lot of money so a hundred
billion doll company so that's uh so 10
10 figures is a billion 11 12 a 12 fig
company there you go um and just uh the
only thing that Rivals the the business
success that he has is just the humility
uh that he brings to it he was willing
to hop on a call with me before this and
uh we hit it off and uh I was like I
just I know my audience would love to
talk to you uh and and just kind of hear
your perspective of Entrepreneurship and
you have such an interesting story that
I think will relate to so many people in
my audience from the people who are just
trying to figure out what they want to
do uh to make money all the way to you
know right now the 20% of my audience is
uh you know winning entrepreneurs with
you know large companies and and so
forth so we definitely have the gamut
from an entrepreneurship perspective
kind of beginning middle and end and um
yeah so thank you so much for taking the
time to join us today it's a great honor
to be here Alex thank you so much I'm a
big fan of the Pod and I think what
you're doing is making Business and
Entrepreneurship um I mean very similar
to the Mion Chava you're making it more
accessible and I think that is the
coolest thing in the world this idea
that business was out of touch for most
people both financially from a capital
perspective or because of knowledge and
insight and experience I think those
days are long over and I think we were
going through an entrepreneurial
Renaissance right now and I think people
like you and and your your community uh
is leading the way on in that front well
I appreciate it and I mean everything
that we do is um just for everybody on
the Pod is I know Harley and I agree on
this um is to just try and break down as
many barriers between where people are
and where they want to be right A lot of
people have this vision for their lives
they want and there are things to get in
their way some of them are between your
ears some of them are between your hands
and keyboard and so Shopify has taken a
lot of that between hands and keyboard
out of the way to decrease the friction
of actually getting a product launch get
it online actually get customers you can
do it from anywhere in the world which
is uh again something that 30 years ago
just wasn't really a thing and now
everyone can have access to this stuff
so um I'm gonna go I'm gonna kind of
break this uh po into three kind of
sections Loosely uh so first kind of
Chunk I want to talk about looking back
and I think that'll that'll relate to a
lot of people who are listening or
watching right now kind of like Zero to
Hero like what what got you to hear and
all the things that that that come with
that uh Second chunk will over what's
hero to to superhero right like what is
what's the for what's forward look like
what's the future look what do you see
um and I'll dive into some more you know
specific details around that stuff and
then at the very end we'll go kind of
like final nuggets and wrapping it up of
of like forward and backwards what are
kind of like the principles and truths
that um that you would try and pass on
to the people who are listening cool
love it let's do it all right that's our
road map so I know a little bit about
the story but my audience doesn't um so
you have this really unique thing of
being employ won and customer one can
you walk us through like just the
beginning of shop like even the decision
to jump into Shopify what what the risks
that were associated with that what was
life prior to that and then like what
what were the this the the factors that
got you into that um step one because I
think that's where a lot of people are
right now yeah uh so I was born in
Montreal I was born in Canada uh I moved
to South Flor with my parents and my
sisters when I was very young uh I was
always entrepreneurial my parents did
not have a lot of money
um but my father to his credit u my
dad's an immigrant he came to Canada
from Hungary in the revolution my
grandparents are Holocaust Survivors I
mean we are you know we were we were
poor immigrants um and although my dad
never had much money to give me because
I always had these little silly business
ideas when I was a kid what my dad did
for me which was very valuable was e
even like when I was like 10 years old
every silly business idea that I had he
would validate it by actually making me
these business cards that would say the
name of the business and my name on it
and I'm now a dad I have two daughters
Bailey and Zoe who are five and seven
and now that I think about parenting and
stuff I'm I'm like I think a lot more
about that that story and those stories
of my father making those business cards
because at the time it didn't seem that
profound and in hindsight now is you
know a father myself I realized these
small things that we do for our kids
have this massive impact and so even
though these businesses were all very
silly you know uh trading like trading
cards and lemonade stands and eventually
a DJ business when I was 13 years old I
was always an entrepreneurial kid and
partially was because I thought
entrepreneurship was this fun activity
like I I wasn't really into sports
playing them or watching them uh I
wasn't really into video games I was
kind of into like this idea of like you
know selling something and that was
always fun for me uh moved to South
Florida went uh finished high school
there and moved back to Canada when I
was 17 2001 to go to Mill University uh
Migel is in Montreal where where I live
now I went to Miguel because it was
cheap my parents didn't have much money
and so because I was born in Canada I
kind of got this like instate tuition
thing unfortunately very quickly uh once
I moved to uh to Montreal to sort of
Migel my dad got into some trouble and
our family lost everything and once
again I sort of you know pulled out this
tool that I'd been tinkering with
throughout my life called
entrepreneurship um to to make some
money I started t-shirt business when I
was at Migel made t-shir for a bunch of
universities across Canada like the
promotional t-shirts you got the first
day of school fro Frost or orientation
uh stuff and I loved it it was great I
wasn't necessarily passionate about
t-shirts but I love this sort of idea of
of of been a being able to support
myself and and help my my family I was
really can I hit on this real quick
because I think absolutely jump in
anywhere you want yeah the the point
that Harley just made I just want to
underline which is that the first
business he had one I don't think that
you thought this is going to be the
business I will have for the rest of my
life this is my dream this is my vision
you were trying to make money right all
is um
and I think a lot of uh people who are
aspiring are trying to find this like
perfect puzzle piece that's going to fit
all of these things it's going to be my
passion it's G be fulfilling it can be
the next Amazon when a lot of times I
think it's a big fallacy because the
first business just gives you a little
bit of light to show you what the next
step to take is because you learn a
bunch of stuff from that first business
that's right and so I just want to just
take the pause for the audience that
everyone's like I got to find the
perfect thing when promo shirts for
freshman and sophomores it glamorous
right it's it's it's not glamorous and
in fact the only unfair advantage that I
had was that I was selling T-shirts to a
customer who was who I also was part of
that demographic meaning like I was
selling T-shirts to the student council
treasurer or procurement office so they
can give them out to students and I
myself was a student and so the pitch
that I made was that one I very low
overhead because it's just me I was I
was the CEO and the janitor I was I was
printing t-shirts myself uh so one I'm
going to be cheaper two I'm going to
care a lot because I really need this to
work and three I am going to make
t-shirts for people like me and so I I
kind of know what your students want
because I myself I'm one of your
students um just to go step back because
I think you said was super interesting
so I I sort of skipped over this but
when I was 13 years old the the business
that really got start like started me an
entrepreneurship a real business was
again I was 13 so uh you know uh I
wouldn't put too much you know uh
Credence on the fact that it was a real
business but it was a real thing was I
wanted to be a DJ I was I'm Jewish I
went to a lot of bar mitzvah when I was
13 years old and I thought the DJs were
the coolest people in the world they
were sort of magicians in my mind they
would take a group of people that were
sitting down eating some rubber chicken
dinner in some Hotel ballroom and like
three minutes later using their voice
and using lighting and and music there'd
be a Conga I just thought they were just
they were like magicians I called around
a bunch of DJ companies to ask them if
they would hire me and of course they
said no because I was 13 had no
experience and and didn't know how to DJ
um but because I had this sort of you
know like silly confidence that that
these business cards had provided for me
I had this idea to start my own DJ
company and hire myself so that was sort
of when this idea of Entrepreneurship as
a tool to solve problems was sort of
cemented in my in my very you know
immature young brain and then when I
needed to make money again at 17 as was
an undergrad in college I once again I
didn't even think about you know I
should go get a job somewhere
immediately my thought was all right I
got to start another business to make
some money here so it began I I began to
form this what what is now effectively
my I think it's shopify's Mission it's
also my personal mission which is an
entrepreneurship is this incredibly
powerful tool because it's Democratic
and it allows anyone and anybody around
to start something with very little it
doesn't matter who you are what your
last name is and and who your parents
are my parents were nobody's it matters
how much value you add and so I ran this
teacher business all throughout college
and developed a really good set of
mentors along the way people that I sort
of met and some people were lawyers and
others were these random entrepreneurs
and you know Dove Charney from American
Apparel now he's sort of I guess
disgraced but at the time he was a very
big deal uh starting American Apparel he
was another Jewish entrepreneur from
Montreal and I met these people along
the way and one of those ENT one of
those mentors convinced me uh to when I
finished college to go to law school not
to become a lawyer but rather to become
a better entrepreneur almost like
finishing school for entrepreneurship
and I was uh in inedibly impressionable
I was 21 when I was finishing College
again I had a little bit of money from
the t-shirts but not much and he said
look I'm going to teach law next year at
the University of Ottawa which is the
capital of Canada why don't you come to
Ottawa go to go to law school here I'll
be in town I can sort of help you
navigate the city um and and you'll go
to law school not with the mandate to to
to get called to the bar or ever
litigate or practice law but rather as a
way to accumulate more skills that will
be very valuable as you think about
scaling a business longer term and I was
2005 moved to Ottawa no friends no
family there um and by this point
entrepreneurship was a part of my you my
identity and so like I always did when I
moved to a new place I I asked where the
entrepreneurs hung out and very very
fortunately very luckily I was directed
to a coffee shop and I was told that
there's a group of entrepreneurs that
hung out at this coffee shop every
Friday evening and they called
themselves the young entrepreneurs Club
the yec and um I started showing up
there every Friday and meeting these
young entrepreneurs and one of those
entrepreneurs was This brilliant
programmer uh named Toby who had just
moved to Canada I think couple about a
year earlier from Germany and he moved
to Canada because he met a girl and he
wanted to go be close to that girl her
name is as all people move for that
reason right very very good reason love
is always a good reason to move
somewhere uh and Toby had moved to
Canada from Germany didn't have papers
to work and so he was told that even as
a new immigrant he could start a
business and being in Canada where it's
very cold a lot of snow he loves
snowboarding he decided he wanted to
build a snowboard shop on the internet
in 2005 there were two ways to sell a
product on the Internet the first way
was to sell it through a Marketplace at
the time like eBay was really the more
the most prominent one uh Amazon I don't
think at the time allowed for thirdparty
sellers it was still a first-party
Marketplace so You' eBay and you had a
bunch of these sort of very nichy
marketplaces but eBay being the big one
so you could sell on a Marketplace or
you would pay a company like IBM they
had websphere or Oracle or at or um or
sap all these big Enterprise companies
had some sort of eCommerce functionality
for very large Enterprises for like
Walmart yeah uh and and that would be
like a couple million bucks and Toby did
not like the idea of of renting
customers from a Marketplace and he did
not like the idea of well he didn't have
a million dollars to spend on on
Enterprise software so that was
impossible so he wrote this piece of
software um using Ruby on Rails where he
was a sort of core developer of rubyan
rails the early days with dhh and a
bunch of really interesting people and
he wrote this piece of s to sell his
snowboards and that's around the time
where I met him he was like just you
selling these snowboards and it was it
was a really neat little business he was
making real money and around that and
and and again I was I'm in law school
now and so I'd asked him if I can use um
the software uh to sell my own my own
products which in my case would be
t-shirts and by that point he had
already sort of figured out that the
snowboard business was a good idea but
the software that he had written uh to
sell these snowboards was a great idea
yeah and uh and and shortly thereafter I
ended up uh building a store on Shopify
this is 2006 at the time and I became
one of the first people to use what
would become uh at the time it was
called jaded pixel it wasn't actually
called Shopify originally um and I would
be one of the first people to use the
software and I built this I I ran this
t-shirt business as direct to Consumer
licensed t-shirt business all throughout
uh law school and um and that was sort
of my first entry into into Shopify
meeting Toby and then when I finished uh
finished grad school um I called Toby
and said look like I love
entrepreneurship it's it's everything I
I think it's it's the greatest thing for
me it's my passion my hobby I wanted I
want to increase the surface area for
more people and honestly what I
experience building a beautiful scalable
store sitting in my tax law class on
Shopify um I think more people should
experience that and um and I joined him
about a year later in in 2009 or so uh
and I was like the first non-engineer to
join the company uh and uh and it was
amazing it was one of the greatest I
mean I just it was I have really fond
memories of those very early days but
that's uh long answer short question of
how I got to Shopify no this is perfect
because that's this is a great pause
point because there I was writing down
some notes just for the audience um and
then I want to definitely we're going to
go from like okay you're now in Shopify
and what are trials and tribulations
because of course I'm sure going from
that to 100 billion was probably just
straight line very smooth sailing you
haven't had any issues um and I'm sure
everyone will be glad to hear that very
short story but we'll get to that one um
but just everyone who's listening number
one um the first business that Harley
started was just for money and it wasn't
just some magical thing that was going
to be perfect he did what he had to do
and he learned a ton of skills that
really valuable along the way second
thing is that uh and I want to emphasize
this is people a lot of times are like
man I don't know what to sell or what
business should I start and I think the
easiest one to use is just solve your
own problem scratch your own edch
totally like almost every business I've
had
well every every really good business
I've had has come from that which is
like like I mean even the the furthest
one we have now because not com a family
office and I wish I had had this
available to me when I was scaling up
our companies like somebody who'd
already been there sold multiple times
and like had a vested interest Etc um
but scratching your own itch um also I
want to highlight some people kind of
get segmented in one thing or the other
like you did a physical products
business but earlier you done a DJ thing
even though it was not you know you made
money so you made a profit and so like
in my mind like self-employed whatever
like it was a service space business so
you had a service business and you also
had a physical product business so you
were flexible in terms of how you were
willing to make money and I was AGN I
was agnostic to what I was selling I
mean to your point you know I I I think
one of the easiest ways to figure out
what to sell you you know you said
scratch your own itch another way to do
it is simply just to like tell a bunch
of people that you're thinking of
starting a business and just leave it
out in The Ether the reason that I
started selling T-shirts to universities
was as I told people that my dad wasn't
around anymore mom had no money I needed
to make some money I need to start a
business the more people like I spoke to
about that a lot of the ideas that I got
were dumb but but more and more people
started telling me hey what about this
hey what about that most of the things
that they mentioned were not great ideas
but then someone randomly his name is
Jamie once told told me remember this
like they perfectly clear he said hey
just so you know Migel spends
$25,000 a semester on uh on t-shirts on
printed Li un printed promotional
t-shirts it turned out he was wrong
these universities spent a quarter
million dollars it has to be way harder
than that right but because I was
putting it out there this thing that I
was looking sort of business a bunch of
people sort of became almost like um my
my my idea generation machine and so
this whole idea that like I know there's
there's a lot out there about like don't
tell people your goals and and and and
keep things to yourself I I call
I think do things and tell
people is super important even at the
early stages of starting these things
well I'm a big I mean my second book
$100 million leads uh advertising is the
process of making no and so if no one
knows about your stuff no one can buy it
they must first know about it in order
to buy it and so if you just think about
it from a first principal's
perspective ain't no customers if they
don't know uh so first way to do that so
two things that I also want to highlight
so you talked about two different types
of people that you surround yourself
with one was mentors so just for
everyone in my audience we're talking
people ahead right and then the other
thing was the community of peers right
he had the coffee shop where he met Toby
who ultimately you know got got you into
this thing again by chance but both of
those thing increase your luck surface
area the the amount of different
potential opportunities for exposing
opportunity well yeah and so um I just
want to highlight that because a lot of
people feel like entrepreneurship is
lonely and it can be but to a degree it
is a choice right and if you can't
physically move environments uh you can
do it online now and that wasn't
available back then but now we've got
online communities we've got school
we've got you know all these things
where people can connect um when I say
School SK o.com school um people can
actually connect and meet one another
all right now uh the last one is
resourcefulness and this kind of ties
well into kind of the next the next
chapter of this journey which is that
like you did all this stuff like
you Toby wrote code so that he could so
he could sell his snowboards right like
it's there's just there's a there's this
whole like everything of course our
whole mission is to make things easier
make things more accessible to people
but on some level like it's the fact
that it becomes difficult is what makes
the goal worthwhile right and if if
everyone could do it then everyone would
do it and then it would no longer be
worthy right everyone can tie their
shoes everyone can get dressed and so no
one's like congratulations there's this
whole um I think Chris Rock's kit where
he's like what do you want a cookie he's
like man I ain't never been pris he's
like you ain't supposed to go to jail
right and he goes this whole thing and
so right now like the fact that it's
difficult is just another barrier that
somebody you might have to compete with
will have to go over and so it gives
yourself a little stripe that you can um
show yourself about who you really are
all right also remember remember this if
you kind to think about like if you kind
of um go back to I don't know go back
200 years and you think about starting a
business um the one thing that besides
Capital to get started and knowledge and
understanding and Technology to help you
do it forget all that stuff for a second
one of the big risks of starting a
business historically was that the cost
of failure could affect your life in a
very adverse way meaning um when my
grandfather came to North America from
Eastern Europe he started an egg
business he had a little egg stall at at
at a local farmers market which actually
still stands today my uncle currently
runs it um but he had to take a loan out
on his home in order to afford the the
fee and the the cost of actually renting
this particular stall if this did not
work the result of that would be no food
on the table no roof over their head and
that is that is effectively how
businesses were built so that people
with more Capital were able to take more
risks people that had more Capital were
able to invest more uh people that had
more Capital were able to have you know
be able to mitigate the cost of failure
well one thing that has changed
dramatically and I would say today like
literally right now Alex you and I are
talking about this the cost of failure
of starting a business today is by far
the lowest it's ever been whether you
use a product like Shopify or use
whatever you decide to do the cost of
failure is effectively $39 if it works
you scale it um literally like three
feet from me I have um was a gift um
from Ben Francis who's the founder of
gym shark and it's a Christmas gift he
gave a holiday if he gave me it's the
original screen print from the original
Jim shark uh the first t-shirt he made
it was it was M Ben's Ben a big part of
my life and I've been I think a big part
of his life and so his gift was the
original screen that created the first
t-shirt uh for Jim shark when Ben
started it was 2012 out of his dorm room
if it would have gone if it would have
failed he would have gone back to class
I mean he was literally also delivering
pizzas I think for Pizza Hut at the time
if I get that right or some some pizza
company but if it worked he would go on
to build a multi-billion dollar company
called gym shark so think about that the
upside and that was 2012 that was like
you know 12 years ago the upside today
of starting a business is effectively
infinite growth if you do it well and
you're smart and you're adding Great
Value the downside is a couple less cups
of coffee or a couple less Starbucks uh
for that week that is
remarkable and I think that um I mean if
there's anything that like there's one
underlying Point here it's the um it's
risk adjusted return right is that
everyone here and now can get endless
shots on goal right now because of how
accessible entrepreneurship is you
basically just keep taking lottery
tickets and if you lose then you just
buy another scratch off right and you
try it again and so you still have the
upside except the thing is it's not
rigged for you to lose like there
actually is a lot of people who want you
to win and there's an entire economy
around you um well not just that right
now what that's created is nearly a
quarter 25% of us consumers in 2024 are
considering stting a business that's the
highest I believe it's ever been number
two is since 2021 there's been 15.5
million new business applications in the
US an 85% increase from 2004 to 2021 the
White House put out a bunch of stats on
this recently I mean that is the reason
that it's happening is not just because
technology is getting better and not
just because of great podcast like like
and content like you're putting out
there it's because people are realizing
that entrepreneurship may be the vehicle
for them to actually find their life's
worth work make their life better create
Independence like do the thing that they
love most this is a pretty exciting time
for entrepreneurship and I think the
cost of failure thing is a big part of
it so now you're employee number one non
non-developer employee number one you've
you've used the product you fell in love
with it and this is now aligned with
your calling so walk me through kind of
the the stages of growth and I'll if you
can give kind of like internal external
so this is what was happening externally
maybe Revenue levels customer levels
things like that and then mirrored what
does that look like internally so I'm
shifting a little bit towards my my
business owners right now all right so
now we're talking like okay we've got
the business we're we're generating
Revenue are is it cash flow positive do
they have investor like how how what's
yeah just give me the the scoop so we
were bootstrapped um we had um a very
very small angel investor um in early on
which um his name is John um he's he's
now a multi-billionaire I believe um and
uh so so was his wife uh separately cuz
she also put some money in but it was a
very small amount of money we were
bootstrap we were profitable um and we
we when I joined we didn't have a CFO we
didn't have a CMO I mean part of what I
viewed my role as and anyone who's
listening who is joining a very early
stage company uh as a non-engineer like
the person not running you know writing
code um or or Building
Product the the role that I wanted to
that I felt I should play and that I I
think I did play was this Swiss army
knife let me figure out everything and
anything that is going to be valuable to
the people that are writing code and
whether that's commercialization or
sales or support or I mean literally
figuring out like where we're going to
like work at of like like figure
negotiating the lease uh for it or um
figuring out you know what are we who
are we paying for I think we were paying
Rackspace at the time like negotiating a
Rackspace contract I think at the time
we only had one payment integration
which was the PayPal negotiating the
PayPal rev share was very early days
this sort of Swiss army knife type model
I think was really really important
because I mean the the you can be the
greatest salesperson or marketer in the
world if you have a great product
matched with a great ability to sell and
commercialize that's where this thing
gets really interesting and I deeply
believe that Shopify even back you know
in 2010 had this incredible product
Leaps and Bounds uh better than all the
competition the competition at the time
was like Yahoo stores or were a couple
other like but very very few competitors
and so this idea of being a Swiss army
knife was important and that's what I
did I you know if there was an
opportunity for me to tell the story
publicly um to a local newspaper in in
Ottawa Canada I would take that
opportunity if there was an opportunity
for me to help someone get a job done
internally I would take that opportunity
but that Swiss army knife was that that
sort of model of that was very very help
helpful and as part of that um I think I
earn the trust of of Toby in particular
but but also you know the other
Engineers because I was just there to
add value that's it in fact um i' I'd
actually been called to the bar and so I
think my like I was I was also the
company's lawyer and again I I've been
out of law school for all of 10 months I
think at that point but whatever I could
do I was going to do that and it was
only a couple years later we we raised
our series a about a year later I think
it was a $7 million uh investment from
besser who L it um on a $25 million I
think post um and then and that's really
when we began to realize that okay there
is a real there there that this company
could be something remarkable large
scalable and we can really make a dent
on at the time it was really we were
focused on smbs and e-commerce only very
different than today where we do
businesses of all sizes and Retail
everywhere but it was smbs and and and
it was it was e-commerce only and it was
only until you know after our series B
and C that we began really figuring out
like okay what what are each other's
superpowers and and this idea of rather
than all of us become these sort of
well-rounded objects these sort of
riverstones what if we all were very
precise on the thing that we think we
could be the best in the world at and
spend our time level did you start doing
that so if we're walking through this
because right now probably around
probably like around series b or series
C we began we hired a CFO we hired a CMO
we hired a had sales it was around that
time where we felt we were well
capitalized I think our our series B was
about 100100 million valuation uh this
is like 2013 or so around that
time um don't uh I have no I mean yeah
I'm not sure a lot less than than $100
million many employees were around then
just I'm just trying to get a uh
probably uh probably 50 to 100 at that
point okay yeah yeah okay got it so like
low small midsized got it okay cool um
and and a lot of what we were trying to
do then is like find you know find at
least a lot how I spend my time was find
new channels so this idea that okay we
can only sell so many people on Shopify
but there's this m massive
ecosystem of web agencies and
Freelancers and developers who are in
Oklahoma and are in you know uh places
like South America and they're in
Singapore and they're in Vancouver and
they're in you know New Mexico and what
if we actually created something whereby
if someone walked in to their agency to
their business and said I need an online
store what could we do to actually make
it so that they would say by default
great we'll build it on Shopify that's
sort of on the referral side on the
product site another thing that was
really um that we created around that
time was the shopy app store which I
believe today is one of the largest
ecosystems of thirdparty developers on
the planet I mean if you are building an
app for Commerce today the best most
effective go to market strategy is to
put in the shopi app store because you
have millions of of customers for
applications that that now seems you
know polished and and a really healthy
kind of flywheel of an ecosystem but
originally the reason that the app
stores really set up was
all these different Merchants were
coming to us and they all had a very
unique and and a very particular
business and so we really focused on
let's make shopify's core offering what
most people need most of the time
checkout payments inventory marketing
anal analytics let's make that like
world class but everything that is very
specific to a particular Merchants
business let's invite third parties from
all over the world to build apps on top
of it which meant that no matter what
the particular needs of your business
might be you would find 100% product
Market fit using Shopify because of this
app ecosystem and we didn't have to
build everything ourself which would
have been impossible and so some of
these things now in hindsight seem like
wow shop ecosystem is really cool and
the App Store is is is is is humming but
originally it was done because we
couldn't build every feature ourself nor
nor should we so what what were some of
the like absolute key decisions or like
business principles that you learned
kind of scaling through this um focus
was really important not being
everything to everyone I mean today you
know um last week was was the national
retail federation's Big Show literally
like the most important conference in
Enterprise retail um and I I sit on the
board now of NRF with like the likes of
the CEO of of you know Brian from Target
and John from Walmart and like you know
these amazing people like that that run
effectively all all of retail uh in all
over the world and so now we're really
obviously you know getting some of the
biggest retailers who Shopify but there
was absolutely no way we were even
considering that in days because
fundamentally we wanted to win our
particular Market which was
smbs in in English-speaking countries uh
that wanted to sell on the internet and
so one thing that was really valuable
was like Focus don't sort of and a lot
of our competitors by the way ended up
going out of business because they kind
of ran up Market way too soon and they
left the entire base of smbs um
available um they didn't like the idea
that smbs you know some churn and not
every business succeeds and we thought
well what if we just slightly increased
the chance of success and mitigated the
risk if every single person thinking
about starting a business like in the in
the shower in the morning then did so
with Shopify even though not all will
succeed as long as the ones that do stay
with us indefinitely they will offset
the cost of ones that leave and so one
was really making sure we were very very
focused the second thing that was really
important to us I think was that the
product was super simple and you know
now company like I don't know Mars or or
Mattel or Staples or you know uh uh
glossier uh Alo yoga view all these
amazing Brands all you Shopify skims
like and what's neat even today about
Shopify is that the complexity of the
product almost reveals itself over time
rather than simply being inated with
every single feature and functionality
Shopify can be used by someone just
setting up a store their mom's kitchen
table it also can be used by Trina who
runs figs which is a publicly traded
company uh they make uh uniform scrubs
uniform scrubs uh hospital scrubs and
and the fact that the same codebase can
make those things was something that was
always important keep it really really
simple and credit to Toby and his sort
of vision around product because that's
really what he he drilled in all of us
was that the the product has to be
incredibly simple so first is focus
second is Simplicity and the third one
was we really tried to run a really
tight business meaning we knew what our
sort of CA to LTV ratio is so cost of
customer acquisition on one side versus
lifetime value and as long I don't know
if if you're I want to make sure I
Define all the acronyms
um okay okay so we knew what our cact to
LTV ratio was and once we got it above
one effectively it meant that okay now
it's time to go raise money because the
more dollars we put on the left side the
more dollar 80s or whatever the ratio
was we got on on on the right side and
so by being meticulous and thoughtful
about that um I think it was really
helpful maybe the last thing I'll say
which seems a little bit soft but it's
important to say we were really really
like patient meaning we want like even
today we want to build a 100-year
business we're now about 20 years into
it we had 80 years left to go but even
then when we were you know five eight 10
years in we still thought about this
like really long-term business focused
which meant that we were not willing to
pull forward future profits at a
discount like pretty much most of our
competitors I think were doing at that
point so what were what were some of the
key growth kind of levers that you were
able to pull throughout this process
that like really accelerated like if you
had to name the three biggest things in
the first 10 years of Shopify that like
man if we hadn't done this we wouldn't
have been able to get to the next level
I mean I think the App Store the
ecosystem is really important both on
making sure the product had a product
had a 100% product Market fit um and
also in the referral side I think that
was really important because it meant
that we had a we had effectively uh a
distributed Salesforce that wasn't on
our payroll and
just something small on that that really
matters I remember at the time the Apple
iOS store had uh an 8020 rev share split
so if you built something um on um on
app excuse me had a 7030 rev share split
so you buil something on Apple you as a
developer keep 70% 30% goes to Apple and
I remember when we were talking about
our rev share for our app store we
actually said 8020 not that we were
competing with the Apple the iOS store I
mean we were we were a small little
nothing company in Canada but this idea
that we would be more generous than the
incumbents might be was very important
and the truth is the additional 10 10
points didn't really change it for us
but it just meant that when you built on
Shopify you deeply understood that you
were going to get a very fair and a
generous rev share split and that was
one I think the second one uh we we
really hammered hard was this thing
called um the build a business
competition it was like our big aha
moment uh and it was you know we we had
an article in New York Times about it
but it started in a very kind of simple
way um we had met Tim Ferris I think in
2009 or so and he became an adviser and
Tim is now a very good friend to both my
me and Toby And and we've done his pod
he's a great guy but Tim looked at
Shopify and
said great product you guys are missing
something most people even though your
product is great easy to use and you're
making entrepreneurship more accessible
most people have a risk adversion to
some entrepreneurship for one of two
reasons either too expensive or they
don't know how to use it and he had this
idea that we should create a competition
whereby someone would start a brand new
business on Shopify um like Jan one and
six months later the store with the
highest sales would win I think we said
$10,000 and then Tim said it's got to be
100,000 we did not have $100,000 to give
out that way but our Hope was that by
the time the competition ended we would
actually have that type of money and we
launched the the the first build of
business competition uh in 2010 um and
it got us you know I think the article
in the New York Times I have to go check
but I'm sure your listeners will keep me
honest here but I think it's like a
startup starts their own startup
competition like launches their own
startup comp it was because it was kind
of a silly thing that we ourselves were
starting a competition the winner that
year was a compy called dodo case that
made these beautiful um uh beautiful
leather iPad case it was the year the
iPad was coming out and so that was one
of those ways where if you sort of read
sort of the Jeffrey Moore uh I think
it's Jeffrey Moore cross in the chasm
book where he talks about you know
technology adoption Cycles go from early
adopters to mainstream it felt like the
build the business competition helped us
cross the chasm from early adopters to
the mainstream and and over over I think
we did the build the business
competition for like five years after
that and ultimately the stores were
getting like Jim shark won one year uh
and and like some Nick SAR won one year
like these big companies ended up
winning uh but so we couldn't give out
100,000 anymore so we had to come with
these new ideas like how do we
incentivize the creation new businesses
and we did things like the winner would
spend a week with Richard Branson on
neker island and the winner would go and
spend like go have lunch with Seth Goden
and so we created this really cool stuff
but I would say that's probably the
second sort of Vector in terms of growth
we found a way for us to cross the chasm
I just want I'll pause right there we
I'm a huge fan of the the build of
business competition and oh you know
about it oh cool yeah yeah yeah super
super well acquainted with it oh that's
so bring up yeah that was I mean that
like that was something that was really
really important maybe the third thing
that I think was probably um really
valuable was we began to look at what
are the other things like what is the
relationship that our product has in the
lives of people that use it and the
relationship started to look like when
someone said they were going to work in
the morning what they meant was they
were opening up their Shi admin on their
laptop or on their on their desktop so
if we were becoming the center of like
their day-to-day work where they added
products and fulfilled orders and added
new SKS and and ran marketing campaigns
um what else can we do to be valuable to
be helpful there one thing that most
people don't realize today uh which is
the case I'll bring it back in a second
is that if you were to pretend today
that Shopify was a single retailer like
if you were to aggregate all our stores
just in the us alone we would be the
second largest online retailer in
America after Amazon okay why is it
important because if you are the second
largest online retailer in America and
you go to negotiate rates with payment
gateways and shipping companies and
Banks and all these different types of
ancillary Services the economy of scale
that you have is so massive well even in
the early days back going back I know
let's say 2013 2014 or so as we were
thinking about adding new features new
functionality we call Merchant Solutions
we began to think about in that way
whereby could we go and negotiate the
best rates from from the payment
gateways as if we were the second
largest retailer we weren't second we
were the 20th at that point or the 30th
at that point but we were able to get
economies of scale because of the
aggregated size of our Merchant base and
instead of keeping those economies to
scale for ourselves we gave them
directly to the merchants we took a
little bit of margin because we want to
make money but we gave so using Shopify
you know to buy a domain using Shopify
to uh to figure out who's going to
process your credit card payments uh
with in your Merchant Gateway it became
much better to you to do it through us
than do it on your own and over time
that has turned into things like Shopify
payments and Shopify capital and Shopify
shipping all these big parts of our
business today we're built on this
philosophy that we have an unfair
Advantage because these economies of
scale and if we give it to Merchants it
means that Shopify plays an even larger
role in their lives so the three big
growth strategies the first one is you
had referral Partners so you made it
easy for other people to basically work
on the platform and promote your
platform because if if you're a web
agency and people want to store then if
you make it easy for them and maybe they
get some sort of financial incentive to
do they they got a REV share for it yeah
we gave them a REV share I think at the
time in perpetuity like 20% of whatever
we took they got which is awesome which
for an agency is a as you probably know
like recurring cash flow is is King yeah
and it's on and what's interesting about
it is it's on a business right so it's
not like uh so basically as long as the
as long as the quote customer continues
to sell stuff you get a REV share
basically Forever on the business which
is a great longterm I mean it's it's an
incentivizing offer so also these these
agencies are not going to build their
own e-commerce stack right so they
needed someone might as well use Shopify
and I this up because a lot of the
business owners that I have you know
they're like how do I how do I grow
right and so that's why I wanted to
really zero in on some of these growth
strategies so one is you had referral
Partners you brought in you you were
generous with them uh to the app
developers and to the web stores they
got 20% of the of the of your cut
awesome uh the second one was you you
had a really sexy competition um and so
I I talk about this in terms of like
making offers to to an audience it's
like how can we make it so good people
feel stupid saying now right like and so
for I would say that obviously it worked
I mean I've heard about it we modeled it
at school I just made the largest
investment I've made um into a platform
so we saw that so we have the school
games and so we really looked at a lot
of the stuff that you guys did there um
try to make it fun and um but the the
key point is that you made it fun you
made it competitive you got you got
customers to compete against one another
but they're all winning um and the major
and this was one point I still wanted to
ask so is it um was the New York Times
the only promotion that you did for that
or was there other things that you did
like was it all word of M like how well
at this point like when we started this
like Tim was just sort of coming out the
4our work week I think was in its second
edition but he had this massive audience
and part of the cool part part of the
the the the Beauty and the value of
working with Tim was not just he gave us
a great idea we're like great Tim now
you gotta help us tell the world about
it also so if we would have gone to Tim
with this idea I don't know if he would
have said yes but the fact that it was
like Tim's we got Tim to generate an
idea for us it was his idea he felt
personally invested in in fact he's I
I've heard him say this on his on his
own show where he'll say like you know
he's one of the co-founders of the build
of business competition I love that
because we created a a real vested
interest in him to actually make this a
success and it wasn't just New York
Times I mean there was a lot of Articles
written about it but it also it gave us
a narrative a thing that we were able to
go and talk about it was difficult for
me to go around and talk about I'm a
like you know I'm sh's Chief Storyteller
it's it's it's it was difficult for me
to go around and talk about like
software Ruby on Rails or the Simplicity
of e-commerce but it wasn't as difficult
for me to go around and say hey we
created this thing we think we think
everyone has you know Nike convinced the
world that if you have a body you're an
athlete like mind mind blown so so
brilliant we were trying to go around
and convince the world if you have
ambition you could be an entrepreneur
and so I had now this new beautiful
asset piece of ammunition that I was
able to go around to media and to the to
anyone that would listen to me to blogs
to celebrities and say there's a thing
here we'd love you to talk about like oh
that's kind of cool that was really
helpful and so for the business owners
at home um one big one obviously was Tim
got involved and so if you're like how
do I promote my business finding a brand
Champion or finding somebody who I mean
there's if you've seen um I think is it
is it air that movie that's uh it tells
the story of U Jordan's like yeah so
like sometimes you need to find like if
you're like if you have an audience
awesome then you already know what
you're doing but if you don't have an
audience you're more of a product person
and you're like shoot how do I get this
to the world sometimes finding your
Michael Jordan and in this instance like
Tim was probably the Michael Jordan for
that era for that for entrepreneurship
definitely right for entrepreneurship at
that time um and so being willing to and
I'm sure that Tim had a good deal with
Shopify for you know I'm sure that there
was a deal with Tim that worked out
there was for sure that he's profited a
lot from um and so sometimes you just
got to be really generous like the
Michael Jordan deal was first of its
kind it was it was it was kind of crazy
the the the founder you know the Phil
was like I don't know this like should I
really go all in on this person and
sometimes you got to make bets right and
obviously this bet paid off the Michael
Jordan bet paid off and so you come up
with something really sexy and then you
find somebody who's the perfect fit for
it and then you put it together right
and so just as like and there's always a
perfect fit right there's always someone
out there there's someone who if if if
if you're if you have a product physical
product or P of software digital product
there is someone out there that has
purchased from you even if you're a
small business who probably has some
sort of Leverage meaning they have an
audience they have a community they have
a big newsletter they have a big
following they know a bunch of people if
they have bought your product
organically and they have a connection
to you organically you asking them Point
Blank hey I have this crazy idea you
seem to like my my my tea um and I would
love to feature you in a promotion would
you be interested that is very different
than cold calling them and saying hi I'm
Harley from this Tea Company uh from
Firebelly te and I'd love you to be a
spokesperson like I think the days by
the way especially go back like to come
to present day for a second the days of
Brad Pit Hawking Colgate or or
toothpaste are over nobody wants these
artificial um connections or
sponsorships when you look at what Jimmy
Mr Beast has done with Feasta BS or Emma
Chamberlain with coffee or you see what
Kim Kardashian is doing with with skims
because these are all on Shopify I have
a very deep understanding of these
businesses these are authentic real
products that were built curated
organized by these incredible
celebrities who care so deeply about the
product like so the the days of
artificial sponsorship pay to play thing
I think are over and I think I think
what we did with build a business was
almost like showcase that hey Tim's for
some reason interested in our business
hey Tim how do you think we can grow our
business oh that's a good idea we'll do
the competition but by the way we need
your help for this
competition and it's it was really meta
and I I want I just really want to hit
on this because this is what a lot of a
lot of businesses need growth right
they've got a product they're like how
do I let people know about it and
obviously you can you can run ads or if
you already have an audience then you
already know that stuff but if you're
like well shoot how do I do it Scrappy
right and so like making an incentive
that gives people a big reason to say
yes right finding a brand Champion that
already has distribution can can be the
unlock because all of that acquisition
is really just based on the negotiation
you have with that one person and if
they can bring a lot like every you have
the opportunity to make a true win-win
and obviously Shopify want and Tim want
and the main one all of the people who
built stores were the real winners here
um and I'll bet you some of the winners
on the stores also did the exact same
strategy that shop was also doing and so
you've got a te company and they find
Mrs T on I don't know on Instagram who
just loves tries teas all day it's like
if she really did like the product then
she would be a spokesperson so just
finding that out okay cool and then the
third one you said um and I want to zero
in on this was it was the econ so you
said growth strategies and you talk more
about the economies of scale was that
just that because that seems a little
bit more product focus and I'm I'm game
for that I just want to make sure that I
I yeah I think on that one I mean it's
product focused but it's also just
simply like business focus my my ability
to go and negotiate with a large payment
Gateway every year got easier and easier
why because I was coming to them as a
much larger Merchant now if you just
take a very simple uh you know a very
simple example 10 individual Merchants
go to negotiate with the payment Gateway
on their own they're all going to get
some rates but if I do it in aggregate
with all 10 my rates are going to be
much much better and I can literally
give those 10 Merchants the exact same
rates you know less maybe you know a
couple basis points that I want to keep
for myself from from a profitability
perspective that kept getting bigger
that doesn't mean by the way we can talk
about you know shop you know like our
our whole shipping thing because we
divested shop shipping uh what's called
sfn shop fil Network a couple months ago
about a year ago at this point because
there are sometimes we have got into
areas that were not main quests we sort
of call them side quests that maybe we
shouldn't have done on our own in fact
in the case of shipping we found another
company called flexport um whose main
quest is an end to-end Logistics
platform which is what we were trying to
build oursel and rather than build it
oursel we're like you just do it and
that we can talk a bit about the value
of what some companies are very very
good at partnership I think shop is one
of those companies if you look at what
we've done with a firm for buy out pay
later or Global e around crossb payments
we've really we pride ourselves in being
a company that is a really good company
to partner with which is very unique in
Tech which is sort of all kind of
fresque yeah and I wanna and I I'm gonna
I'm gonna bring this to the the brick
and mortar chiropractor like so just
just down to to home base um those
relationships don't need to be these
massive Billion Dollar Deals obviously
they work at scale but you know I think
about I think okay so if I'm a
chiropractor what are all the things
that um anybody who's my customer also
gets they might go to the gym they might
like smoothies they might like uh yoga
right they make other things that are
ancillary and I think okay well what if
I go to each of those businesses and say
hey with every smoothie just put a
coupon you can slap it on there for a
free adjustment so they're going to get
a free adjustment and a smooth like
you're going to enhance the value
proposition that you have to your
customers at no cost to you but then I
get free leads and so it they get a win
and then I get free customers or at
least a free shot at a customer yeah and
so these Partnerships and and you know
this has been a huge core to every
business that I've built is I mean I
think I've built almost the same amount
of revenue from Partnerships and
affiliate relationships um as I have
just from act you know direct sales and
generating them ourselves because you
are known as like I mean you know you
and I know each other sort of from
Community our our own communities like
you are known as being a good partner
meaning you leave enough on the table so
your partners can make money from it you
know uh doctors actually do this really
really well on their own referral side
meaning if you go to see a doctor and
that doctor can help you great they
they'll they'll they'll work on you if
they can't they'll recommend someone
else if you what I've noticed is that a
lot of them recom like it's almost like
a a closed loop circuit where Dr a if
they can help you always recommends Dr B
who always recommends Dr C and and Dr C
always recommends Dr a and sort of this
I think if you're a chiropractor for
example you if you sort of vend diagram
out meaning you look at your customer
base and you ask them you know where do
you go where do you work out what
clothing do you do you like to wear what
where do you go to get your smoothies
for example you probably have your own
version of that but also the people hang
in the Smoothie Bar are also asking the
Smoothie person hey do you want any good
chiropractors and the yoga instructor is
also saying hey I think you need a
chiropractor as well and so creating
your own version of an affiliate program
even if it's not called an affiliate
program it's sort of your own creation
of it actually is incredibly effective
and if you overd deliver meaning every
time the chiropractor recommends the
yoga instructor uh the you know the yoga
instructor's client comes back and says
man that yoga instructor you recommended
is amazing you should send more clients
to that yog instructor and so there is
an opportunity to sort of overd deliver
to create even more leverage in this
sort of closed ecosystem of reciprocity
and I'm going to give everyone three
quick tips on this number one if you're
going to create one of these
relationships give them customers first
if you give them customers first they're
way more like send them five people and
then make the call be like hey by the
way I thought maybe it'd make sense if
we did some now they're going to want
more of what you J just gave them and
they're going to be happy to talk second
one is in terms of generosity like if
you know what your cost to acquire a
customer is you should be willing to
give at least that for referral to a
referral partner because like you either
pay Zuck right or you just pay another
small business owner and I can almost
promise you that a referral from a
partner is going to be worth more in LTV
so you still get a a better LTV to C
ratio by going to a stronger Channel
with like a referral partner um and one
little thing that uh Lila's really good
at this and she has just drilled it into
me over time which has been helpful for
Partnerships is she says never count the
other guys's money yeah and so just
because you're making someone else a ton
of money like it has nothing like if you
take out how much that person makes and
you just look at your side of the table
make the deal make sense for you if they
make a killing awesome they're going to
be an amazing partner right and so I
just want to underline that for because
some of the mistakes I made early on is
I wanted I saw how much I would make but
I've lost deals because I got too greedy
trying to say well he's gonna make even
more than me and I would encourage you
not to think that way because if
everyone grows such it's such an amazing
reminder so I don't I don't watch sports
I don't really play sports so my Sunday
project this is a little bit weird and
nerdy but I I I have this project it's
called Big Shot it's an archive that I'm
creating of the greatest stories of the
greatest Jewish entrepreneurs of the
last half century and so I'm meeting
these people most of them are in their
80s and 90s and I sit down with them and
I record it I put on YouTube it's not a
big podcast just it's mostly a personal
project but it's fascinating and i' I've
sat down with people like Izzy sharp
who's the founder of the Four Seasons
hotel or um a guy named Larry
Silverstein who's the owner of the World
Trade Center these were poor kids I mean
these people grew up with nothing zero
um or Fran Weisler who's the queen of
Broadway way these are very poor people
that grew up and and and eventually
created you know they're billionaires
and they've created Empires um when you
ask them at 90 years old and so I think
Izzy sharp from the Four Seasons Hotel
is 95 years old when you ask these
people tell me one or two things that I
don't know I'm I turned 40 this year so
Izzy tell me something I don't know that
I should at my age almost to the I've
done about 12 of these interviews so far
with these like older you know icons and
legends on Titans almost all them to a
te say make your partners really really
rich now the reason I I bring this up
now is because these are people in their
90 in their 90s who they got nothing you
know they're not trying to have Swagger
they're not trying to like Flex they're
so and the reason I love interview them
is because they're so transparent but to
a te every single one of them from these
Titans of industry in real estate to the
the the the queen of Broadway has always
made their Partners incredibly rich and
that is not something that is intuitive
but it's something that I think like is
is
legitimate
I I I love I love this entire line of
thinking because um I mean it goes down
to the just more of abundance mindset
most of the people that I know they were
wealthiest in the world just don't see
business as a zero some game yeah right
it's just like everyone actually can win
whereas in a lot of games it isn't it
isn't structured that way uh whereas
like even just the the build a business
competition you mentioned earlier like
sure there was one winner but do you
think that number two to number 100 in
on the list was like oh man I'm so
bummed that I only got to 100 that's the
craziest part number two number and
number 100 are have built million-dollar
brands also right and that's this idea
of like positive some thinking I think
is so important I know there's like you
know like I'm an optimist I know you are
you were also Alex but one thing that I
think people Miss is often when you go
to raise money for those of you that are
looking to raise money one criticism you
often get from investors is this concept
of Tam total addressed Market how big is
your market and effectively what they're
trying to say is that if you look at
your Market it's a pie and your Tam is
effectively the pie and your your your
market share is a slice of the pie I
think that's very flawed thinking and I
think if we would have done that at
Shopify we would not be a hundred
billion dollar company our version was
not let's take a piece of the pie rather
let's grow the pie itself and so um
we'll get to the IPO in a second but we
took our company public in 2015 May 2015
on the New York Stock Exchange it was a
billion dollar company at that point so
um but you know um 1% of the market cap
that is today at the time um every when
you before you go public you in this
road show we did 93 meetings all over
the us and you're meeting these
investors and you're meeting These funds
and you want them to invest in these big
funds that have trillions of dollars
under management and this idea of Tam
would come up over and over again and I
needed to have an answer for what the
Tam was and I remember it off by heart
it was there were 46 million retail smbs
on the planet I think I think at the
time we had 100 or three 200,000 of them
so big big growth opportunity ironically
if you sort of you know we're now nine
years past the IPO if you look at
Shopify today a lot of our customers are
not uh just SBS we have very large
companies we're also well beyond
e-commerce we have tons of merchants
uses for point of sale physical retail
we have t we have a capital business a
payments business there was no way for
them to actually to for me to give an
answer around Tam in terms of like
foreshadow what we would become and so I
love this idea that you're talking which
is like positive some thinking and
optimism where share share the wealth
that other people around you because
rather than sort of thinking of the pi
as sort of this finite space think about
the pi as infinite and encourage more
people to participate that's how you
build these like generational
hundred-year multi-billion dollar
companies I talked to a fund manager um
the other day and he was uh and he has a
public a public fund and he was he was
saying you know one of the things that I
really like is that I've got 10,000
people praying that I win every
night isn't that great yeah and I think
Zig Ziggler said something to the degree
of like you can have whatever you want
in life as long as you help other people
get what they want first um and I I just
I just really really believe that
because I've so I actually feel like
I've actually put some numbers to this
but I think that from an
entrepreneurship perspective it's about
on10th and what I mean by that is like
you get to keep about one tenth of the
wealth that you generate for other
people and so I've just seen that from
like the number of entrepreneurs that I
look at like how much the market cap
like not market caps the U like total
revenue that's run through their
platforms versus how much their Equity
stake is and what it's valued at like
the amount of times that I've seen that
equation done where like it's 10x like
you have to make 10 times the amount of
money for other people as you'll be able
to make um it's just been really cool
and I think framing it that way is like
how do I make everyone else a ton of
money
like everyone loves doing business with
someone who makes them money and then
they like and then they will want you to
keep doing business with them so
2022 our 2023 numbers are not out yet Q4
earnings are coming out soon so can't
talk about that but I'll tell you last
year in 2022 shopify's Revenue was but
$5.6 billion under six billion our
Merchants the people that use Shopify
made almost $200 billion doll in in gmv
and revenue and sales that is I mean
that is amazing I'm very proud of that I
love the fact that our Merchants made
200 and we made Five Point something
like that is the that the reciprocity
that I think is important we I also love
the fact that our our ecosystem Partners
made more than $6 billion dollar last
year that matters because it means for
2023 they're going to come back and work
with us again and so I wanna I this is a
really good line of thinking for I think
a lot of the people in the audience so
one is we we've got this big theme of
reciprocity and what are what are some
of the other because I'm I'm skipping
one ahead but I think I think I think
it's worth it so what are some of the
you asked you put this question which is
what are some of the things I don't know
it should which is actually a question
that I ask people too so I I like that
you asked that question what are some of
the other things that came up from those
conversations or just things that you
would share um as some of the big
breakthroughs and like really ones that
you were like I really thought this and
I was dead wrong and I see this now and
it changed everything um all right let
me go uh a little personal for a second
because I I think um these conversations
don't really add as much value unless
you can sort of take off the facade yeah
um I have I turned 40 two months ago my
wife turned 40 a month ago so we've like
been doing a lot of like reflection on
our life and and you know we're grateful
and we love what we do we're doing our
life's work and all that but one of the
things that I really believe on a
personal level is more true to me now
than ever is this idea that
vulnerability is actually this
incredible superpower and my life has
gotten dramatically better when I became
a lot more vulnerable and I'll give you
a quick example um I became I was I was
the chief operating officer of Shopify
between pretty much 2015 or so in 2020
so post IPO until sort of the
pandemic and I loved being shop coo um
it was a big role I had thousands of
thousands of reports and most like
pretty much all the non-engineering
organizations you know rolled up to me
and I I thought that was cool I thought
that was really fun and and and I felt
good about that but I I wasn't I wasn't
happy um I didn't feel necessarily that
I was the best coo in the world um but
there was no way in hell I was ever
going to raise man and say this is not
the right role for me this is not what's
going to keep me at shop ofite for a
long time and it was only until I had a
really good chat with Toby and I was
like look I was like um like there is
someone who's better at this role than I
am I'm certain of it and turns out it's
Cass who's our current COO uh he was
initially he was running product for
payments for us our money product but
he's now he he loves being the COO and
running operations the way that I love
storytelling and I never would have had
this new sort of this next gear of of my
career at Shopify had I not had a little
bit of like just gotten over my own my
own my own crap to say this is
really not for me and I think this idea
of of vulnerability showing weakness as
being this like weird bravado insecurity
thing I think the more you show
vulnerability the more you ask for help
the better things become and I recognize
that it's easier for someone like me to
show vulnerability at my stage than it
would have been for me to show 10 years
ago um but I actually I I'm as I get
older I I believe that less and less
that I actually believe at any stage
being really honest with yourself and
being honest with the people around you
about what you want to do what you love
doing what you're really good at like
this idea of I've mentioned the term
life's work a couple times there's a
great Japanese term which is iy guy
which is effectively like what do you
love what ises a world need what can
what can you get paid for that idea of
of finding your thing at at a stage in
life where you're not 95 like Izzy sharp
from the Four Seasons but you're 40 like
like like I am or you're 50 or 60 or 30
I think is a great gift and I think
you're able to find your thing a lot
easier when you simply are a lot more um
vulnerable about that and and more more
than ever I I really look at that today
as as as a real strength that's the
first the second thing I would say is
even uh Shopify is you know we have I
don't know eight or nine thousand people
at the
company Shopify is very much a Founder
Le company but also the people that work
at Shopify have this incredible Founders
mentality
they act like an owner with every
expense that they spend um the Speed and
Agility they use um they reject like
best practices quote unquote they
reject processes that don't make don't
make sense don't make don't make it
faster and not just that we encourage
that if you look at the most like some
of the biggest areas of Shopify They're
ran by founders of companies that we've
Acquired and they've stayed at Shopify
long past the earnout dates because
we've created this sort of crafters and
Founders Paradise at this company in in
many ways it is like this this
incredible like um Collective of
Founders and and and entrepreneurs and I
think that you can do that at any stage
of company but if you but if you're not
careful it goes away really quickly and
there are very few companies at our size
today that feels like a founder-led
entrepreneurial everyone calls
themselves the largest startup like it's
it's almost you know it's such a common
thing to say it's it's most of
them are not like that and I think one
thing that you can do as the founder of
your company is instill this Founders
this Founders mindset or founder
mentality and you can keep it there if
you work at it and I think the results
are almost always unequivocally better
what do you do tactically in order to
keep that so a couple things are very
simple in most companies of our size the
way to to get a promotion is to go into
management there's one track it is and
it's it it always leads to a manager
type role um
we don't do that there are other tracks
that Shopify there is a manager track
there's also an individual contributor
track or we call the crafter track there
are these other tracks that allow you to
stay at our company for a long time and
if your craft is engineering or it's
product or it's sales or it's
storytelling and it's it's sort of brand
building we are absolutely in fact not
even okay with it we are going to be
super happy if your mandate for your
career is to get really really good at
being the world's best marketer or the
world's best sales rep or the world's
best whatever um so one is we've created
these different tracks at Shopify and
we've cre which is sort of you know like
the way I like to is like Shopify is
really a crafter's paradise that's one
the second thing that is really
important is we also encourage like real
disagreement we invite people to
actively disagree when something just
doesn't feel right um now if like if
we've made the decision we've beat it up
you know dis you know disagree and
commit sometimes has to happen also but
instilling a place where like you
encourage open debate is really I think
super important I I I think most
companies talk about transparency and
they talk but it's it's it's total
to encourage that I I just I
always get into the weeds but like yeah
the track makes a ton of sense like that
was like for me you know with with with
our companies like I will I will that'll
probably be my number one take away from
just my tactical takeaway is like
interesting having individual
contributor tracks because one of the
big issues that a lot like when you have
a star media buyer right in a company
that guy usually doesn't want to then
manage media bu like he's us like that
person and why do you want that person
to like you want that star media buyer
to be a media buyer and what if that
star media buyer is a seven and actually
wants to become a nine or a 10 at some
point now all of a sudden you have like
the world's greatest media buyer so one
thing is I think you do have to have a
conversation with people um no matter
what size your company is like what
tracker you want are you in a manager
like there are some people who are just
so great at management you want them to
manage teams they just they're really
good at that stuff but I think having a
conversation say what track are you on
really really matters the second thing I
think that's also uh that's that's also
really important is um I know every
company want likes to talk about things
like you know transparency and and open
communication um we write a letter to
our board um every quarter we share that
letter with the board the whole company
we and it's not redacted it's exactly
letter that even at our size that we
share with the board we share with the
entire company a small now not every
letter is going to be this holy
mindblowing you know uh piece of content
they're always really interesting um but
sometimes you know it's more like making
sure the trains are are are on time and
stuff like that but what it does do over
time is it it really brings everyone
into the same page of like hey the
things we're telling the board we're
also telling you that there isn't these
like two different versions of The
Narrative of the company and um I think
that's something that is it's it's it
seems simple uh but it's really really
impactful especially if you do it really
consistently I'll give a I'll give I'll
give the listeners a tactic that we have
done for this which is um we actually
run open book financials in all of our
companies and so when we do quarterly
it's like here's where we made money
here's where this like we spent money
and it didn't work out well and so
that's helped for everyone feeling like
they're on the same page that we're not
hiding anything and if things are going
really well they can see it and if
something doesn't go as well like some
of the decisions that happened downline
we like well that was suffering and I
guess this this does make sense that we
decided to divest in this kind of
endeavor that we were doing and I know I
love suie but I get it you know like
even even if people aren't like stoked
about it like they get it um so I I was
just I love this is great by the way um
and so acting like an owner you you
operationalize that um by creating
individual uh contributor tracks and by
having manag tracks really so people can
be honest about what they're really good
at and the one tidbit I'll give for
people who actually aren't owners they
just like uh entrepreneurs sorry U
employees in businesses is no one can
fault you once you own your flaws like
if you're like hey I really suck at
project management and if you say that
upfront then people are like they don't
they don't talk behind your back about
it they'll just talk to your face about
it because it's not a secret you're like
I know I suck at project management and
so the more it's like Eminem's whole
thing is like if he claimed every single
deficiency and flaw that he had no one
could say anything back to him in rap
battles and even though you know
hopefully Corporate America is a little
bit nicer than a rap battle maybe it
isn't um yeah I it may not always be but
I think you're right about that I think
also the thing that what what happens is
when you say to someone look I don't
want to be a Riverstone I don't want to
be well-rounded I want to be really
really pointy at at this thing and that
means that these other things around me
I'm gonna hire or I'm gonna find teams
who are really good at those other
things now you're beginning to actually
put yourself in a position where if
you're not like the world's greatest I
don't know writer for example um but
you're really good at like coming up
with like you know great slogans or
you're not the world's great ad you know
you're not great at writing ad copy but
you're a great media buyer now if you
say look I'm not good at ad copy but I'm
I'm so good at finding opportunities for
for great exposure if you say you're not
good at that that means it invites
someone who may be really good at copy
to come and be your like your your your
your your buddy your best your you know
your best friend at work that stuff
really really matters and I I think um I
I think that stuff is really great the
only other thing I will say is this um I
know a lot of compan talk about Mission
and Northstar one thing that we are very
clear on even from from from day one
till now is um we are a merchant
obsessed and what does that mean when
given any decision whereby we have to
pick one of two things we always ask
ourselves what is better for merchants
now by the way that is different than
let's say Amazon for example who is very
famously consumer obsessed they don't
like that's what they care about they're
very clear about that when you work at
Amazon there's like 100 th people work
there they are consumer obsessed by
creating this this very simple theistic
of which allows you to say given two
opportunities both seem pretty good how
do you actually evaluate it well what's
the one that's best for the merchant
that means that thousands of people work
at Shopify on a daily basis are making
independent decisions that all roll up
to that centralized Mission which is we
are Merchant obsessed we care first and
foremost about the millions of of
business owners that you Shopify and
again it sounds obvious but most
companies totally mess us up and where
the the vision emission stuff gets
really important just for everyone who's
listening is like once you get to about
100 employees that's where you're you're
usually two to three levels away like if
you're the founder you're two to three
levels away from people who are getting
hired you're starting to hire people you
don't even know their names like this is
where this really becomes important
because decentralized decision- making
is the only way you can continue to
scale and you need people to make
decisions that would be in align with
align alignment with you like you can't
be in every room to make every decision
and so that's where mission and values
create decision-making Frameworks that
people can use as litmus tests of okay
what would Toby do right now well I know
that Toby says Merchants are Northstar
and Merchants would not like this then
we don't do it right even though we'd
make a little bit more they don't like
it and that's what correct I just want
to highlight that because a lot of the
people I mean obviously we take
businesses on um smaller than
Shopify that we invested but like we'll
we'll go through this exercise with
leadership because usually when they're
at you know between1 to $30 million a
year this is when this gets really
important to get to 100 million a year
uh in revenue and so forth and so like
if you're at that point in your stage
like this gets important I also
think something you're sort of you're
sort of skating or flirting with a
little which which has to be said is I
think that there is a strange thing that
as you grow so you mentioned a 100
people there's actually a real thing
it's called it's called dunbar's number
it's 150 people right and dunbar's
number basically goes back to like the
days of like when we're all living in
tribes that basically a tribe size
should never go beyond 150 there's some
sort of science around humans can only
really remember 150 people at any one
particular time I went through the 150
Mark a long time ago at Shopify it does
change and there's no question about it
but the one thing that often happens
when you cross that 100 Mark or 150 150
person Mark is you begin to do this
whole like um you know macromanagement
you sort of get out of the weeds and
actually I think this whole narrative
that micromanagement is bad is total
horseshit I actually think that the best
leaders I know whether they're running
like trillion dollar companies uh
because I know some of those or hundred
billion dollar companies or million
dollar companies the best leaders I know
are in the Weeds on the things that
matter most and even you know I'm
preparing now for my earnings call which
is in two weeks like I'm In The Weeds on
this like we have an IR team who could
prepare all this no I want to actually
go through every single word in the
script in the press release in the
narrative I want to go like word for
word on my own before anyone even takes
a look at it because it matters so much
and if that's my craft that's what I'm
supposed to be resp responsible for then
I'm going to be in the Weeds on that I
think there's like this this Corporate
America you know bashing of
micromanagement and I I think I I'm I I
think some micromanagement is actually
really positive and needed we agree and
um we have a little saying for this
internally which is win in the weeds
yeah like that's like that's where
you're gonna go Toe to Toe with
somebody's like you're gonna win in the
weeds like that's how you do it and I
like I feel the same way if some cor you
know some some president of some other
company of our size uh is not in the
Weeds on on on earnings on on press on
Partnerships I'm going to run circles
around them because I am in the weeds
because you have the the visceral
knowledge of like the stuff that really
makes it and one of the things that also
helps with this is that if you're in the
weeds when something goes wrong you know
why it went wrong and you can make a
pivot where if your two levels removed
you don't know why it didn't work and
then your decision- making of what to do
next then relies on secondhand and it
gets really really messy after that you
make really dumb moves um okay so we
have reciprocity is one of the big
driving things we have uh vulnerability
and then the Downstream impacts of how
you've kind of implemented that within
Shopify with the individual tracks um
and encouraging open disagreement among
people and giving everyone kind of a
North star so everyone's aligned with
how we're are like what Frameworks are
we going to disagree around like it's
not whether we're doing customer or
we're doing Merchant the disagreement is
going to be which of these best serves
the merchant if we're going to disagree
correct right so um I want to zoom out
and so I said we're going to look back
and I think we took a little bit of of
final nugget stuff and moved it Forward
which I loved anyways so if we're
looking forward right um you sit in this
really unique perch that I mean maybe 10
people on Earth sit on that you sit on
top of this mountain of data and you
kind of see around the corner and so
what's kind of what's what's what's
what's coming right H what are you what
are you thinking about for Shopify um
and just kind of the marketplace overall
for retail entrepreneurs or even just uh
entrepreneurs in general look we talked
a little bit about the sort of idea that
the cost of failure is trending toward
zero it's never going to be zero because
ultimately like the sort of asmt because
ultimately like you have an opportunity
cost like you could be doing something
else um so it's never going to be zero
but it's getting close to it I think a
couple things around the
entrepreneurship thing one
is I think entrepreneurship now more
than ever before is default Global I
think this idea that we've
imported um physical geographies and
borders of countries in from the
physical world into the digital world is
really silly I don't think I mean you
know you see a lot of great Brands
behind me that I'm close with I put up
uh you know from kth to Supreme uh to
Mom spaghetti which is M&M's company to
Firebelly which is my little T side
hustle um uh master and dynamic
headphones these are some of the
companies that I love that I'm connected
to none of them have Geographic
limitations that's just not how they
operate I get it it's more complicated
sometimes to sell although frankly we
have a product called Shopify markets
and markets Pro which makes everything
really easy there um but I I don't want
to this isn't a shopy pitch just I think
one like your total addressable Market
when you're getting started is anyone on
the planet who wants to buy your
particular product first second of all
is I think the idea um if you listen to
any of the earnings calls from these big
um big retailers one of the terms you
often hear is this concept of Channel
conflict which is a very simple thing
it's online is doing well but it's
hurting offline Instagram Commerce is
doing well but it's hurting my online
store I I when I think about the brands
that I admire the most across millions
of stores on Shopify none of them none
of them use the term Channel conflict
why because they are Channel agnostic
what they care about is serving their
customer in the way that their customer
loves to be served or wants to be served
which is very different than pretty much
you know the history of retail where if
you wanted to buy bread you went to the
baker uh in the Town Square you want to
buy shoes you went to The Cobbler down
the streets in the 80s I I'm a you know
I'm an 80s kid um when I went to go buy
a video game I'd have to line up at the
store at this hour doors open wait in
line use this credit card no not that
credit card use this one that whole
thing was the concept of the retailer
dictating the process of purchase to the
consumer is over and the reason that
you're seeing you know things like shop
pay for example become so popular is
because seamless simple easy convenient
checkout is what every consumer wants
and so modern retailers today one are
geographically agnostic two are Channel
agnostic they sell across every channel
the reason why you see us do things like
we there's a there's a Spotify channel
for Shopify so if you're an artist most
most merchants on Shopify are not
artists but if you're an artist and you
have your Eminem for example and you
have a great popular artist profile uh
and fan base on Spotify now you can sell
your merch directly from your artist
profile page and Spotify won't be
important to most people but our if we
want to qualify and re-qualify to be the
retail operating system for these
millions of stores our responsibility is
every surface area on the planet digital
physical anywhere in between that a
transaction could happen we have to make
that easy so that's probably the second
thing I think that's happening in retail
and then the third thing that I think is
is kind of like a an interesting thing
um is that I think business is becoming
at all sizes personal and you do this
very well Alex maybe better than anyone
but you know your own personal brand and
your business's brand they're not
separate anymore um a couple uh a little
while ago I saw very uh very highend
brand their online store was down um
I'll say it was Versace Versace went
down I think eight months ago when I
tweeted I said Versace like let me help
you out um and it end up leading to some
of the Versace Brands coming on to
Shopify at that point was I the
president of Shopify was I Harley the
entrepreneur was I Harley the like human
like it I think this idea that that you
know work life balance or work life
Harmony the separate I think it's I
think it's over I think people I think
we as entrepreneurs and aspiring
entrepreneurs in 2024 we have to sort of
incorporate all these things into our
backpack our businesses our personal
life like you know you talk about uh you
talk about your wife Lea right all all
the time about being part of like you
you sort of mix in between total
addressable market and talking about
your wife I do the same thing like
Lindsay my wife is a huge part of my
life and when I go home I talk about
work and I was talking about our kids
and I like I think this there's sort of
this wonderful harmonious situation now
where we don't like we're not separating
these things we're not waiting to retire
to live our life I think more and more
you're able to kind of like have a
personal brand but it's also your
business's brand and you're also an
extension of the company but you're also
your own person and I actually think
that's a wonderful new thing that new
phenomenon um that is very different
than our parents and grandparents and
great-grandparents had yeah and they
don't really get it as I know right I
mean Mr Beast is he a YouTuber or is he
a or is he a confectionary genius with
his chalk who cares he's this amazing
guy he's a great entrepreneur and he
makes content and he makes chocolate and
he makes burgers and he makes cool
videos and he's a cool dude and like who
cares how you sort of categorize these
people um and that's the reason why
actually back to what we said at the
beginning authenticity is going to rule
here and if you are if you are full of
people are going to figure that out
very quickly and they're not going to
buy from you and they're not going to
want to participate in your journey but
if you're not full of and you
invite people along into your journey
and you you talk about your kids and
your spouse and your business people
cheer for you and it goes back to what I
think you said you know uh earlier is is
um that that that quote about you know
you want as many people cheering for you
as possible on your journey forg the
exact quote but if somebody like that
and um because I I like defining terms a
lot it's like one of my hobbies but
defining it from a behavioral
perspective so a lot of people are like
well what is being authentic or like I
want to be authentic like how do you do
that um the best definition that I that
I have that's working is um behaving as
if you could not be punished and so
oftentimes like we censor ourselves for
fear of punishment we like the many
things that we don't say or don't do
because we're afraid someone's going to
say something or someone's going to do
something in reaction and so basically
if you're in an empty room you have
almost no no potential for punishment
right and so it's how you act as if you
could not be punished is how you are
authentically um so we talk about this
concept of like you are the niche so
it's like what is Rogan he likes he
likes he likes aliens he likes you know
weird the government stuff he likes uh
fighting he likes comedy he likes
biohacking he likes taking crazy drugs
like he likes all sorts of stuff and so
if you're to say hey I want to start
this podcast where I talk about aliens
fighting comedy like all like people be
like you're crazy but it's Joe Rogan and
so it also creates a one-of-one category
that only you can really occupy and so I
I I genuinely do believe this um
that everyone is kind of unique um in
terms of their distinct interest and
kind of like if they were a chart like
how how the the point of their Rock is
in one directions versus hundred other
ones and so I do think there is a thumb
print there that that is unique to the
individual where people do become
rounded Stones is because they pull back
on their pointy bits and so then they do
look more uniform and so people look
uniform but aren't in reality and so
looking at these three big things in
terms of what's coming around the corner
in Commerce and kind of like where the
best brands are indexing number one is
that they see everyone as a potential
customer around the world not not not
not just their local area just even
people who speak their language uh
second was that they don't really care
where the customer comes from like if
more people know about your stuff and
you put it in more places more people
will buy it and as long as you treat
them well you'll make more sales in your
more rep repeat customers and then the
third one is creating allow basically
allowing yourself to be you publicly and
being more okay with the association
that's going to happen inevitably with
you starting a company because if you
really believe in the product it's going
to be in mesed in your identity like
it's going to be part of who you are and
rather than caging these things out or
boxing them just leaning into the fact
that like you're you and you own this
thing and I think that what we were
saying earlier with kind of Tim Ferris
and these brand Champions like those
other people can contribute their
thumbprints to your product as well well
if you're authentic then other people
that are kind of like you like you know
I I I like to I like to be exothermic
like I like to take I'm very high energy
always have been um I like to add energy
to other people and other other
situations and rooms and conversations
and so I'm just going to like I want to
be exothermic and so everything that I
do I want to like I want to be the
exothermic person what that means is
people see me being exothermic mean you
and I sort of connected like you and I
are kind of social media friends like I
was being exothermic and you were being
exothermic we're like hey let's be
exothermic together that's how you and I
that's why we are talking right now
because I try to be authentically me on
the internet and you try to be
authentically you on the internet and so
we connected and like Med like yeah we
kind of like each other that you get
tons of people coming at you asking to
do stuff together and immediately you're
like ah something is off here and and I
I I feel the same way sometimes when
people come to me and they say like I
want to connect I want to do a deal with
you um when you are exothermic and if
you are or when you are authentic you
actually invite other people that are
similarly authentic in your way into
your lives and you create these amazing
communities and friendships and
relationships and it's it's really fun
but you know I mean it's it's a great
sort of place to wrap up I think which
is like is a deep optimism I think
around the entrepreneurial community and
for those of you that are listening
whether you're an entrepreneur or
aspiring entrepreneur one of the best
parts of Entrepreneurship is that all of
us not actually not all most of us
didn't sort of start with like some sort
of like we didn't start on third base
most of us started at the beginning and
we've been building ourselves and so
when we see other people building on
their own whether they're chiropractors
or they Tech entrepreneurs or they're
lawyers or accountants or they're
someone who's creating you know I love
my Ember mug I love the the guys at
Ember they make these great coffee mugs
that stay hot whatever they are I am
rooting for them and they're rooting for
me and that actually that's sort of
wonderful like ecosystem reciprocity go
back to that that makes entrepreneurship
a little bit less lonely and also the
greatest tool for humans to find their
own version of success whatever your
version of success is make a lot of
money uh put food on your table be
creative whatever that version is
entrepreneurship is this amazing vehicle
and today it's more accessible than it's
ever been and there's it's tough not to
be optimistic about
that last
question business advice to Harley 10
years ago you got one thing you can tell
him um I think a lot of you know a lot
of people don't know where to start we
kind of talked this a little bit earlier
when we talked about t-shirts but just
find a problem that that you feel
yourself and just solve it um yeah like
it's hard to imagine how to scale and
how big it could become don't even worry
about that but like if there's a hobby
like you know um one of my best friends
is really in is is his name is David
seagull he's the founder of David's Tea
this big tea Empire he sold the company
2016 and he was trying to figure out
what to do and all along the way David
was like coming over to my house and
you're hanging out a lot and he's
obsessed with tea um I was like dude
like you have a thing it's tea why aren
you build another Tea Company and so
that's where Firebelly came from and I
love this idea that like you know the
thing that you're searching for is
probably right in front of you and I I
know some people say that you know you
shouldn't commercialize your hobbies but
I'm not sure I'm not really sure I
believe that like if you have this
amazing hobby this amazing interest this
amazing pain point you feel a lot that's
exactly what you should be working on
that's the first thing the second thing
I think is like you know um I'm this is
my 15th year at shop advice I'm 40 years
old so more than a third of my life has
been spent at this incredible company
and I if if people if Toby and the board
will have me I'll stay there as long as
I possibly can but finding someone who
um like from a partnership perspective
um someone you work with closely
I think a lot of people start companies
and businesses with people that are just
like them people that they would have
been friends with in high school I think
it's fun and I get it um and you know
Firebelly for example Dave and I are
both kind of similar with our little te
thing um but actually I think some of
the most impressive things I've ever
seen built were built by people that
probably would not have been friends in
high school again going back to this
idea of like of pointy objects they're
pointy in their own way but their points
are not the same and by combining their
points they kind of create this like
Avengers thing which on their own they'd
be doing cool stuff but like you know
doing it all together uh means they can
build hundred billion dollar company um
so those would be some of the things I I
would say maybe the only other thing is
like you know one just going back to
like life life and work Al together one
of the most important uh decisions all
of us can make is finding an incredible
incredible partner um spouse wife
husband boyfriend girlfriend whatever um
I think people underestimate how
important that is and I think I I often
refer to to Lindsay uh at her 40th
birthday I said you know Lindsay is my
superpower um that I have this
incredible part and and I I I think we
all not all but I I I know a lot of
people that take for granted um how
important that particular decision is uh
I I think finding a wonderful life
partner for you uh whoever you are um is
just probably the most important
decision you're ever going to make and I
think we all some people think about it
very thoughtfully others sort of do it
halfhazard and I think that's a mistake
yeah 71 correlation with your subjective
well-being hell yeah so is that true are
you making that up no no that's
correlation with subjective wellbe the
strength of relationship with your
significant other um with that I feel
like it's a great stopping point thank
you so much for giving your time like
just just this is so fun I hope it was
valuable to your to your community and
your listeners I'm I'm a huge fan I'm
part of your community and uh I I tried
to bring as much insight and and
thoughtfulness as I possibly could um
it's it's an honor Alex for me to be uh
talking to you for I don't know the last
90 minutes it's beyond mutual and on
just behalf of you know MOS Nation thank
you so
much appreciate you